we're monsters who help and we call
ourselves the helpsters
from the makers of sesame street
i hope this works the helpsters are back
[Applause]
there's no place type home
now we can help anyone with any problem
oh i've got one whoa and just in time
how can we help you
i want to throw a party but i don't know
how well we can help you with that right
everybody
so who's got an idea i have an idea
sounds good try it we're gonna need
party snacks i'll go find ingredients oh
and music hello and finally i need to
invite some friends no no that's
actually not it we have to get them back
into the right sequence
sequence a sequence means the order in
which things happen oh i see first i
have to invite a bunch of friends so i
know exactly how many snacks we have to
get hamster
then we have to get enough snacks so
everyone can eat oh yeah and have some
smoothies while you help
finally after we've had our snacks we
need music to start the dance party
places everyone
ricky ricky rick ricky rick a rick ricky
ricky rick risky ricky rick
perfect thanks
i love working with all you help
seriously who did it everybody yeah we
did high fires and handshakes
what a difference a plan makes
had a big tricky problem at the start of
the day made a plan and the problem
started melting away hooray no matter
how hard no matter how new no matter how
tangled up and tough to get through what
a difference
and
is
and handshakes
high fives and handshakes